this
is what hitler wanted
[Applause]
i'm not proud of that obviously i didn't
mean to i'm just saying
that if you were to go back in time to
like hitler's back cave or whatever
it's just loads of pictures of me
and the kid from home alone
with just like ecliptic written all
around them
ecliptic by the way is uh german for i
love you not i love doesn't matter
um yeah i apologize for being ill as
well i have the sniffles
i don't really mind the sniffles because
it means i get to sneeze
and i love sneezing it's my favorite
thing like people say sneezing's a
quarter of an orgasm
i must say it's a full one i enjoy them
that much
very similar to an orgasm in that you
need tissues afterwards and you
shouldn't do it in a stranger's face
very important to remember the
differences guys
[Applause]
you guys are nice you're very american
laughers and it's not in any sort of
insulting way american audiences have a
very interesting way to laugh
which which is it's very loud but then
it stops immediately
and as a comedian it's terrifying
because it's like
next one
continue and
never really sure of how i'm doing i've
got them they've left what's happening
it's
my parents are very intelligent people
it's very weird going on with
intelligent parents because rebelling
is impossible they're too logical when i
was 15 and go to my mum and my dad be
like mom
dad i'm gonna start drinking
[Music]
[Applause]
and they'd be like well you're 15 years
old yeah
it's gonna be about the age you want to
do that we can't tell you not to drink
alcohol because you've grown up watching
us doing it therefore be hypocritical of
us
to say you also couldn't partake
obviously at first we'd rather drink
under our roof
under our supervision so you'll learn
how to consume alcohol responsibly but
sure go ahead
it's not it's fun fine i love my game
you know what i'm gonna be a comedian
and they'd be like that's amazing that's
a chance for you to combine that passion
and that creativity that we know you
have
and turn into something you love i mean
how about this how about we even drive
you to all of your gigs and let you live
with us rent free for two years guys
what is happening
how am i ever going to be an artist if
you keep supporting me
all of these other comedians their
parents are alcoholics or drug addicts
or abusive you guys have never neglected
me
neglect me fine you want the big guns
i'll bring out the big guns
i'm gonna start having sex
and then they'd be like
okay
you let us know how that goes
martin martin have you heard this i know
with who
look at his face not even a mother
not even a mother could love it and i
would know
you know i heard him on the phone to his
friends the other day do you know that
he calls his junk the sloth ness monster
yeah yeah because no one's ever seen it
am i right i know i'm right
i know i'm right all right you don't
need to please don't
please don't give my penis the clap
that's not
there's no one i can't believe i said
that sorry
my favorite thing like with my parents
though is they're very intelligent
people like my mother has a phd in
microbiology and
biochemistry my father is a computer
programmer
and when those two geniuses started to
combine their dna
they made
so uh one of them probably cheated
it's the only way to explain how this
happened probably my mother
my wreck not because she's better than
my dad but just because you know
it's a lot easier for a woman to
convince a man
that a baby is his
it's very impressive the other way
around
just my dad coming home at two in the
morning drunk
with a baby
it's yours
you